for you being somebody from LA and being
a part of like YG's crew who's in my
opinion the biggest La rapper we've had
in since the game I mean or nip
obviously I think nip got the flowers
nationally worldwide unfortunately once
he passed but YG is like the face of La
rap since it was the game and then YG is
how I look at it you know what I'm
saying um what do you think has been the
disconnect as to why there isn't more
Superstars out of La I feel like the
disconnect for La is and by the way doer
cat's from La shout out DOA cat
sometimes we be just act like sh nah I
literally was having this conversation
the big I was having this conversation
with gut the other night like shout out
DOA she from the city um but I feel like
a lot of us we get too scared to move
outside the box or think outside the box
and we from La [__] get rich and move
here [__] get rich and they want to
come to Hollywood Hills it's like when
you from LA and you get rich where do
you go Vegas save the tax money save the
tax money not at all but it's like so I
feel like it's a hard it's a hard pill
to swallow there but more artists from
here just need to get out and try
different things and try to go [__] with
people on the other side of the world
because when the artists in Detroit get
cracking in Detroit you see them in
Detroit you see him in Atlanta you see
him in New York and then you see him
come to La out here two three months we
get cracking oh yeah we doing a tour
from San Diego to [__] Washington the
Phoenix maybe you know and then maybe
Albuquerque and then we going to try to
do that same two and three months six
months but these other people from these
other bro they're trying and they're
getting out of their state so to every
La artist out there and RI tell you bro
like me and RI argue about this all the
time get the [__] out of LA go see some
[__] go move around you are the lify
yeah RI needs to move to Atlanta for
like a year hey man I might move back to
Atlanta for a year shout out to RI man I
love RI man Rie is a one of them ones
facts for sure shout out to Roach big
roach dog the guy travels with a bong oh
dang yo he the only person I know still
smokes swiers and it's crazy well he's
the only person I know that has a bong
with him in backpack everywhere
everywhere I'm like bro why you
got and it ain't even a small bong this
[__] got a three-foot bung on
him at all times like moving around like
it's like cheich and Chong [__] it's
it's crazy um yeah I think the other
thing too do you feel like
um do you feel like another thing La has
going against it is that there's so many
politics in the streets that maybe at
times can prevent artists from working
together I don't I don't I don't believe
that and the reason why I say I don't
believe that is cuz look pay attention
to YG and nip right they moved around
together everybody you can like I'm not
the most educated on all of the street
politics did
YG did his neighborhood beef with nip
neighborhood though it's Bloods and
Crips right but I think that like as it
don't matter it's still like that's what
I'm saying like people get too jaded or
too lost and [__] like but isn't it more
in La cuz I do think that the outsider
perspective of Bloods and Crips from LA
are if it's a blood or a [__] is beef
when there are blood sets that beef
would blood sets [__] sets to be I mean
the biggest [__] in La is like the
Hoovers versus the 60s you know what I'm
saying like and they're technically it's
not a blood vers [__] thing so I guess
like that I think with YG and nip was it
a little easier for them to nah I don't
think it was I don't think so because
it's like even if it wasn't YG it's
about the people he be around with right
cuz y a blood he hang out with all
Bloods [__] he hang around with a lot of
different Crips a lot of different
neighborhood [__] cards right so I'm
from Swan
ni might have been having some people
from East Coast with him or like y got
homies like baby Dot from Inwood
families and nip might have so and so
from 90 with like it's like I really
believe like so they kind of showed
people it's bigger than the program I
really believe everything is bigger than
the program it's how you look at it like
if you going to be part of that program
like shout out to you go be that but if
you a man first and you carry yourself
like a man no matter what Hood you from
what Hood you in people going to respect
you like I don't be in my my enemies
Hood like doing no stupid [__] but bro
like people see me move around La n
times out of 10 I'm by myself or with
one other person I'm not traveling
around with 30 [__] but everybody in
La know where I'm from but it's how I
carry myself as a man I feel like and a
lot of people don't understand how to
carry their s like a man or really be
scary so they only move around when they
move around with their hood or they only
talk when they got 30 [__] with them
but it's like [__] I I done pulled up to
the 6's to go meet nip or BH by myself I
done pulled up on 60th and Madden to
meet BH by myself for me and Y we don't
need 30 [__] but it's like if BH came
to the east side to the swans he going
to have the same respect like I done had
like bro you got to think like back in
the day bro we shot a video y shot a
video in the school yard's Hood TC from
schoolyard but we had the jungles there
the swans there how TC TC is great man
that's my brother we were literally just
talking [__] on on DM like the morning
before last um but yeah bro it's like I
think it's more in the person and how
the person got respect in their
neighborhood and how they carry
themselves like if your homies respect
you your homies going to respect whoever
you bring over there but if your homies
look at you like you're a mark [__]
when you bring somebody over there they
going to show that you the mark right
like and I feel like that's what La is
really is like of course there's gang
[__] of course there's politics but
everything comes as a man or as a woman
how you respect yourself I just feel
like other cities don't have that extra
layer everyone's got hoods and
everyone's got problems like you know
[__] no bro that's that but that' be the
smoking mirror but I feel like even like
Detroit like it used to be the East Side
versus Westside thing which is still
obviously issues with a lot of people in
Detroit but a lot of that [__] got put
to the side now you're seeing people
from Detroit work together that never
work also seeing other people get in the
middle of it like [__] I'm not standing
for that like Skiller baby [__] Skiller
baby with s baby and he f with t Grizzly
I'm not going to be in the middle of
that I'mma squash it cuz I'm a real
[__] and I I respect both of y'all
skills and I feel like if more artists
or more people carried themselves like
that you'll see less [__] like that but
bro like people I hear it all the time
like La Gang This La gang that but it's
like bro there's gangs everywhere if I
go to Atlanta I'm not going to the south
side of Atlanta by myself if I don't
know nobody from the south side of
Atlanta who's going to move around with
me I'm not scary no but you're not
stupid I'm not stupid I got I got
$100,000 worth of jewy on why I'm I
going to [__] hang out in Harlem well
we should we should uh we should leave
that jewelry at home man no I'm just I'm
don't go to Atlanta with 100 Grand of
jewelry but that's what I'm saying but
jewelry but the Atlanta person come to
LA with 100 Grand of jewelry they get
robbed like come on bro it I feel like
it goes same for St whatever state
whatever city you in if you got respect
for sure and if you move you just got to
move the right way man exactly